[Music]
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you by spectator tv
and broadcast on thursday november 11th
i'm kate andrews the spectators
economics editor and your host this week
on this week's show what started as a
lobbying row with tory mp owen patterson
has become a wider crisis for the prime
minister mps with second jobs are in the
firing line and the tories have been
accused of offering peerages for cash
fraser nelson says the government is in
turmoil in this week's cover piece and
he'll join us alongside our deputy
political editor katie balls and former
number 10 chief of staff gavin barwell
douglas murray meanwhile argues in his
column this week that mps have less
power over parliament than they should
have he'll be on to make his case
and we've managed to ignore it for a
while but brexit is back britain is
threatening to tear up the northern
ireland protocol
are we looking at a trade war with
europe we'll speak to the former uk
representative to the eu ivan rogers
alongside our political editor james
forsyth
then we'll turn to china and america are
we about to see a war over taiwan
elbridge colby a former donald trump
defense advisor says taiwan is crucial
to making sure china doesn't come to
dominate asia he'll tell us why he
thinks america needs to get ready for
conflict
after that we'll hear from emma ashford
an expert who disagrees and says
washington is getting hysterical
and we'll finish by speaking to israel's
ambassador to the uk she attended a
debate at lse earlier this week and was
met by fierce protests when she tried to
leave
why do people want her silenced
before we get going if you enjoy
spectator tv then you should subscribe
to our youtube channel just click the
red button at the bottom of this video
and tap the bell icon to make sure you
never miss an episode
and why not subscribe to the spectators
magazine too you can get 12 weeks of the
magazine and a free 20 pound amazon
voucher for just 12 pounds to take up
the deal go to
dot co dot uk forward slash tv offer
now owen patterson quit as an mp last
week after he was found to have broken
lobbying rules and it was recommended
he'd be suspended from the commons for
30 days
wanting to help out a fellow tory the
prime minister planned to change the
entire system and overturn the ruling
then he backtracked
now a week later the rao has morphed
into a crisis for the government over mp
second jobs and the conservatives
allegingly offering a seat in the house
of lords for donations to the party
in his cover piece this week fraser
nelson says the mess is indicative of
the court of chaos that surrounds boris
johnson how did he not see this coming
fraser joins me now with katie balls and
gavin barwell former chief of staff to
theresa may and author of chief of staff
notes from downing street
fraser you write this week that in
boris's court he may be king but he's
losing his grip
tell us about what's going on in number
10
well it's actually a bit of a mystery
what is going on in number 10 why for
example last week did they think it was
right to lead their troops into battle
over owen patcherson only to reverse
when they realized that they were a
mission impossible from the get-go but
the funny thing is we spoke about this
in last week's spectator tv but since
then you're getting increasing um
noises of disgruntlement from the tory
benches who basically think that this
the constant u-turns the constant panic
and shows number 10 which is
fundamentally dysfunctional now for my
cover piece i spoke to a lot of people
and who who know what's going on there
around the prime minister
um and having somebody in a way i
suppose i follow in boris johnson's
footsteps he was a hugely successful
editor of of this magazine a very
successful mayor of london i always
argued to be a very successful prime
minister as well and not because he was
a sort of great command and control guy
but because he built around him an
apparatus
where people who he liked and trusted
would be able to distinguish his great
ideas from the acts of occasional lunacy
and they would be able to differentiate
i mean stuart reed the deputy editor a
spectator at city hall he had something
like 12 deputy mayors who he'd evolved
power to who were able to understand him
and also interpret him if you like as
foreign secretary he couldn't apply
appoint anybody he was a flop in that
position i'm afraid to say and then
number 10 you'd think he'd getting it
right you'd think he'd find somebody who
he trusted the problem was he got
dominant cummings now dominic cummings
was quite competent but as we now know
he was running an agenda separate to
that of the prime minister in a way that
was designed to exclude the prime
minister from the decision-making
process or a large part of it in number
10. so number 10 is over-corrected from
being a machine where what the prime
minister wants is of peripheral interest
to being a machine where even his bad
ideas get enacted so you remember i mean
kate in lockdown when boris got pinged
he thought he'd give himself an
exemption and not self-isolate in the
way that hundreds of thousands of others
were happy to self-isolate now you
should have an advisor there saying
boris that's obviously a mad idea of
course you need to lead by example
you're
you you cannot possibly um get yourself
out of this jail you've created for
other people but no it went forward and
it led to a public uproar and then only
then did the u-turn come so we're seeing
a dysfunctional number 10 more of a
court i argue than the government and
full of people who aren't really telling
him the truth the truth right now is
that things are pretty bad and they're
going to get worse instead he's being
told it's okay it's all a bit of
westminster gossip you can carry on in
fact his approval rating is now down to
-26 a new low for him and the opinion
pool lead over labor has evaporated
so there is i'm afraid to say a lot more
downsides to come
katie as fraser's getting out there the
prime minister when he first came into
downing street was surrounded by very
strong advisors some might say too
strong
now it seems that he's surrounded by yes
men whose role is to enact whatever the
king decrees
is this an over-correction that we're
witnessing yeah i think we can see a
shift between two systems and around the
time that dominic cummings left
alongside lee kane other members of the
vote league team though i remember
writing a cover piece for the spectator
where ultimately um you know lots of
people including ministers are saying
let boris be boris he's been too
strained in there's been an attempt to
box him in and actually where the prime
minister really excels is getting out
there
speaking more
you know going about doing things he
wants to do rather than going this tight
script and quite a defensive approach by
the vote leave team
i think that you can agree with some of
that criticism and then look what's
happening now and it's almost as in it's
almost so boris johnson at the moment
even if you look back to tory conference
um the leaders speech it was
very much boris johnson's greatest hits
playing to the crowd very light lots of
jokes and you can see in one hand why we
got that because it was the first annual
meet um since the election victory given
that the last time it had to be
cancelled but it's also the case that
someone said is this really um you know
appropriate should there be a bit more
warning people about quite tricky months
ahead and i think that
you see it with the own patterson affair
in the sense that uh the fact that boris
johnson
thought he could push through with this
and no one really stopped him and those
who did stop himself we said it to him
but he didn't listen that there's almost
a loss of the checks and controls and so
it's not to say you should go back to
how it was you know a year ago but it
definitely feels as though you're going
between extremes
gavin there are different ways of
running number 10 under blair the
cabinet had less influence at least say
compared to someone like david cameron
who often let his ministers get on with
their briefs under theresa may you have
strong advisors again like nick timothy
fiona hill we can throw yourself into
the mix is boris johnson do you think
just being managed particularly badly or
is the system itself flawed
so i think i think first of all you're
right that there's no identical way to
run number 10 that you've got to get a
structure that works for whoever the
prime minister is
but it's it's not a question of boris
being managed badly he he himself has
got to take responsibility for the
structure he sets around him
and as fraser was saying this is not a
one-off this the patterson uh affair was
the worst example
but if you look at the number of u-turns
that we've had from the government that
shouldn't be happening when you've got a
majority of 18.
so
this is not a one-off incident i think
that's what what's worrying conservative
mps that they're seeing repeated
instances
of where the government digs itself into
a position which is clearly untenable
and then has to sort of scramble out of
it now
what's made this particular
case so damaging for the prime minister
standing within the parliamentary party
is first of all that it was so obviously
a mistake i mean
it didn't take long for this one to play
out essentially the moment the
government said it was going to back the
leads from amendment people were
predicting more hang on the opposition
is just not going to take the seats on
the committee and then the whole thing
is going to blow up
and secondly it's obviously had huge
impact on conservative mps themselves
both in terms of the feedback they've
had from constituents but then the story
has clearly moved on to some of the
you know some of the second jobs that a
number of those mps have
so
it's not i think a question that the
prime minister has been badly managed he
himself needs to take responsibility for
the operation he has around him and that
means you know either
there isn't anyone that told him this
was a bad idea or if there is they're
not people whose judgment he is
accepting and he's got to find someone i
thought fraser's
example of city hall was a really good
one you know you first of all had simon
milton then you had eddie lister
two people who who he clearly trusted
his judgment he clearly trusted and who
he listened to and he needs to
make sure that he's got someone around
him in number 10
that has the confidence to say to him
when he's making a serious mistake and
whose judgment he is going to trust
katie do you think boris is ready or
willing to accept change to the system
in downing street and artoria mp's
telling him that the way things are
running simply isn't working
so tory mps are fed up after the past
week or so the own patterson event i
think has ultimately confirmed quite a
few of the fears they had about the
operation and i also think it's the case
that
um and fraser has been covering politics
longer than me but i've never covered a
prime minister where tory mps are
delighted with everything they do uh
maybe the day after a big election
victory but there's always going to be
some complaints and therefore you know
it's often what you hear is number 10
has too much power i think that there is
a growing sense though that the
flip-flopping the u-turns the changing
of the decisions and means like you know
you keep hearing uh toriyama saying you
know he needs an old hand he's a senior
figure and as fraser writes in his cover
piece um you know eddie lister perhaps
being trying to tempt him back but
perhaps not
not something that he's particularly
keen on former close aide the fact that
ben gascoigne from the city hall group
is is returning um as a deputy chief of
staff you are seeing you know some
personnel changes but i do think that
the problem is given there is
dysfunction for some time now is uh
questions of what is the answer to that
is it a senior older figure or does
ultimately boris johnson need to
reassess how he governs and maybe it's a
decision by him as gavin was touching on
to actually listen to some of the people
he already has there and because there's
enough people briefing out or getting
friends to brief out they warned against
this um just as you heard with the
self-isolation rather saying oh no i
said this is a bad idea so
maybe their voices need to be a bit
louder and also the prime minister needs
to accept that actually sometimes to be
a good prime minister you have to listen
to advice you don't want to hear
and act on it
and fraser you mentioned in your cover
piece that perhaps the solution to this
or at least the start of one is that
boris should think about running a
government instead of a court
yes and recognize that the current set
up isn't working for him
let alone the party little in the
country this is not
the boris johnson we're seeing now looks
a far less impressive figure than the
one that we saw um a city mayor
the city mayor did not make these
massive u-turns did not let these mad
ideas uh take the wind so often and he
needs to work out why that is and part
of it is personal he actually finds it
rather difficult to trust people
individually and i mean gavin might will
know more about this but i think the
same was true for theresa may she wasn't
a particularly gregarious person and
didn't have around here many people who
you trust i guess that's true for for
most of us really i mean how many people
would you really um to to have a chief
of staff we're talking somebody'd have
to pretty much trust with your political
life i mean how many of us know somebody
who we completely trust their instincts
and to take the decisions that we would
or rather the better parts of ourselves
would take it it's very difficult to do
but it's so important for a prime
minister to find somebody like that
to find a willy a willie white law to
find a david wilson defined a a charles
powell in tony blair's case and for
borders johnson it's absolutely crucial
i mean when he became tory party leader
i remember writing a call and thinking
well it is unless he can find
his stuart reed his deputy editor his
his liege this will not be a successful
project he absolutely needs somebody
like that and maybe because dominic
cummings let him down so spectacularly
he feels a bit stung that and thinks
well maybe i'm going to just to try to
to keep on and just keep things in my
head just not really let people in but
no anybody who has worked with boris
johnson and i know a lot of people who
have worked very closely with him over
the years will tell you he absolutely
needs um somebody by his side to be his
interface with the rest of the world
he's an incredibly private person he and
he doesn't really take people into his
confidence it's very difficult to find
out what he's thinking even if you're
trying to work at what broad direction
he's going and he takes even his closest
aides by surprise so far as quite often
and he says contradictory things almost
as if he's trying to the way he thinks
he argues both sides of it out aloud so
if you listen to him you're not quite
sure which side of your argument is
coming down on so he does need to find
somebody to succeed dominic cummings he
needs that pretty urgently i'd say
because there are some laws of gravity
political gravity you can define for
very much longer keep on governing like
this you will lose your reputation for
confidence of competence he's already
lost his reputation for cutting low
taxes and soon he might lose his
popularity and after that he better be
careful because the tory party won't put
up with them if he thinks if they think
he's become a liability so gavin how
does the prime minister decide who to
trust
so it's a really good question i mean
normally the person that you would
appoint into that kind of role as
someone you have known for a long time
for exactly the reasons phrases said so
if you think about
my predecessors nick timothy and fiona
hill teresa had a very long-standing
relationship with them
so my appointment was really a sort of
exception to the rules because we didn't
know each other very well and she took
uh she took a big risk
um
asking me to do the job because we kind
of had to learn how to work together
while you know on the job essentially i
had to get to know her very quickly in
order as chief of staff
you know i understood her mind and could
could speak to senior ministers and
officials about what it was that she
wanted to do
you
know
essentially sometimes as chief of staff
you you function a little bit like the
oracle at delphi people don't want to
bother the pm at the weekend necessarily
but they come to you saying i'm thinking
of doing this what would the pm think
so that that
if he hasn't got someone
who's who's close to him already that he
has in mind for the job he is going to
have to take a punt on finding someone
who he believes he can develop that
relationship with and yeah and as frozen
said it isn't easy uh it's it's an
important choice to make but he should i
think have learned the lesson
uh over the last few weeks that this is
something that he desperately needs
uh and i i completely agree with what
praise is for the moment
forget the government or the tory party
the current structure isn't working for
him
and it is his own personal interest let
alone the party's interest or the
government's interest to put that right
katie last word to you it's quite clear
that he's going to have to change
direction
uh but arguably he's in a tough spot
he's already gone through a lot of his
former colleagues who he might call into
the role
yeah it's interesting when um gavin's
talking about uh how you know if it's
not someone you immediately have that
relationship with already you've got to
take a punt well you could say it's what
the prime minister did with dan
rosenfield
and
by all accounts i mean as much as dan
rosenfield is still in position the fact
that these things are happening when he
is chief of staff for hearing dan
rosenfield said that you know he
shouldn't press on with his own
patterson plan um and that was briefed
out and on reading those reports and you
know hearing from others that this was
the case that dan rosenfield wasn't on
board um you can help think is this
actually a helpful briefing for dan
rosenfield because for me it's just
confirming that as chief of staff he
doesn't really have the prime minister's
ear and i think that's problematic so in
terms of where you can look obviously
you can go to old people you trust um
but given that the prime minister's
fallen out with some of those people
others are looking at down history and
thinking perhaps the more quiet peaceful
life is not there and is is a tough one
and that's why i do think as much as he
does need a senior figure you've always
got to say what can he work with in the
immediate and medium term you have nigel
adams that is a old-timer old retainer
um np uh close to boris johnson
supported him for his different
leadership campaigns he was promoted in
the cabinet reshuffle to a role which no
one quite fully understands but has
something to do with obviously um acting
as a go between boris johnson and the
parliamentary party and i do wonder if
looking at his longtime supporters you
can find a few people like that who come
together and make a difference
fraser katie and gavin thanks for
joining spectator tv
it might sound like there's not enough
oversight of mps but in his column this
week douglas murray says unelected
officials have the real power to explain
douglas joins me now alongside james
forsythe
douglas thanks again for joining us on
spectator tv you write in your column
that the most boring conversation in the
nation is back what is it exactly
yes lords reform um who doesn't quiver
slightly when they just hear those words
lord's reform is one of the most boring
conversations in britain because it's
essentially unsolvable and it's happened
and gone on throughout all of our
lifetimes um
many of us remember the debates in the
1990s over this particularly with
getting the hereditaries down um ever
since then there's been intermittent
claims and calls for more reform and uh
the reason it's so tedious is because
there really aren't any good options uh
uh
intermittently people claim well just
scrap the entire chamber that's a
terrible option because you do need a
second chamber to revise legislation
every way you look at how it should be
made up you enter all sorts of trouble
and then you get the one which we're in
at the moment which is the perennial
cash for peerages debate and you know
this is serious because we all worry
about the way in which money influences
politics it's uh i think that in many
ways britain is lucky that we have less
uh buying of influence and then many
other democracies actually um but the
the the peerages issue is always going
to be a strong one because
effectively if you don't have
state-funded political parties and
political parties need to raise money
through private
donors and trade unions in the case of
labor
people are going to have to be given
some incentive uh to give
millions of pounds to a political party
simply through the good of your heart or
through
something else is a strange thing to do
not very many people would do it so
there need to be inducements there are
going to be inducements and one of them
and it's an open secret is that if you
give enough money to a political party
you may find yourself able to be
suggested as being a potential peer it's
not a great system at all i i don't like
it anymore more than anyone else uh
but as i say
what are the other options
james it hasn't been a good week for the
government has it can you give us the
latest update with owen patterson
jeffrey cox and the cash for peerages
story yeah the government has basically
created a scandal that has run all week
and i think is beginning to do real
damage to the tory party
it's actions in trying to stay the um
the guilty verdict against her and
paterson
and then gonna try and reform the rules
on the back of that was so brazen it has
created a backlash
it has got everyone looking at
mp's second jobs and it has put boris
johnson in a very difficult position
he's having to choose whether to be on
the right side of public opinion uh or
the right side of his own mps because i
think if you're judging from what mps
say they're getting in their inboxes
there's no doubt that most of the public
question why mps need to have
the ability to earn money other than
their 82 000 pounds a
uh parliamentary salary
yet uh at the same time
mps tory mps and particularly more more
traditional tory mps think uh a
they have these outside interests which
they are reluctant to give up and they
also think i think this is not an
invalid point
that if you basically bar mps from doing
any other work other than their
parliamentary work you are going to
limit parliament to those who wish to be
professional politicians
and you are going to end you know the
ranks of kind of qcmps that you had you
know i think people think people like
ken clark or michael howard uh and but i
think that would narrow the experience
available to parliament and i think it
would denude parliament of quality i
think one of the problems we've already
got at the moment
is that there is a tendency for uh and
theresa may is an honorable exception to
this there's a tendency for former prime
ministers to kind of quit the comments
as soon as they've left office i think
if you if you if you banned all outside
interests i think you would find that
nearly all former cabinet ministers quit
the commons as soon as they had left
office
douglas you wonder in your column this
week whether trying to reform the lords
and the commas misses a crucial point do
our representatives even have that much
power in parliament anymore
yes this is something which i've been
reflecting on for a long time as i
mentioned not just in relation to the
house of lords but the house of commons
as well
um you know remember one of the the main
uh the main slogan of the brexiteers was
take back control
and i say in my column this week
when the british public voted to take
back control from unelected bureaucrats
in brussels
i do not think that we intended to take
back that control and give it to
unelected bureaucrats in westminster
and this is a subject which as james
well knows has been bubbling for a long
time among both mps and peers about who
actually has primacy in their own houses
um now it seems to me without going into
the details of it it seems to me the
owen patterson affair has an awful lot
um
that it suggests about our democracy not
functioning well uh i believe that the
oversight that occurred was seriously
lacking
uh and it and you know
basically what occurred would have been
impossible in a judicial setup owen
patterson effectively wanted his day in
court was not given it partly because
the person who was judging him is not a
judge
um she's an absolutely typical
archetypal bureaucrat
um
and there was so much wrong in her
investigation but then you end up in
this position of course which was made
much worse by the the ridiculous
u-turning of the boris johnson
government i mean if you're going to
spend political capital as they were
going to do
spend it and and and see it through
don't spend it and then then you turn at
the first uh cries of complaint but but
the real thing is not just the oversight
of mps and the oversight of mp's um
extracurricular or extra activities
but also in the same in the house of
lords
james douglas is pointing out here that
he thinks that the oversight mechanisms
currently in place can sometimes be too
powerful that's certainly something the
allies of owen patterson have been
saying these past few weeks on the flip
side of course especially in light of
the jeffrey cox revelations you have
people saying that there simply hasn't
been enough oversight but it feels to me
like we're getting to a far broader
point here and perhaps a more crucial
one which is
what is the job of an mp and how much
time and dedication should be put into
that craft as opposed to other kinds of
work
so i i personally think that having mps
who
uh carry on with their former
professions and trades while they are
back bench mps
can be healthy um for example just
constitutionally we have an attorney
general and solicitor general in our
system and an advocate general for
scotland they all need to be lawyers so
you do need a certain number of lawyers
to be practicing in the house of commons
and you know i think you know michael
howard and ken clark are examples of the
fact that you can combine a successful
legal career at the bar with a
successful parliamentary and political
career
and
that i think is healthy i think where
things become more dubious is when mps
are being paid for kind of political
intelligence or things like that
rather than for carrying on with the
jobs that they were doing but i also
think we have to make choices as a
country uh i think we lament the fact
that there are so many professional
politicians in the house of commons we
lament the fact that there are so many
um if one was being unkind kind of super
counsellors in the house of commons
if you don't want to have that
then you are going to need to allow us
to have a system that does allow people
to uh not to have to entirely give up
their previous careers when they become
politicians and i think that is that is
striking that balance now i think you
can get into specific arguments about
how long people should be away or not uh
and i think jeffrey cox the fact that
jeffrey cox has spoken so little in the
house of commons in recent times doesn't
do him any favors
but theoretically i have no issue with
someone being a qc and carrying on
earning more from their legal practice
than they do as a backbench mp as long
as they are speaking and participating
in debates
and generally raising the tone of uh
just scrutiny of legislation in the
house of commons and i think this
applies this argument applies um
even more forcefully to the house of
lords if you are to hugely restrict what
lords can do then i think there are
fewer people will enter the house of
lords because the the dirty secret about
the house of lords is but the house of
lords doesn't have very much power and
the households will never be reformed
because the house of commons does not
want the house of lords to be reformed
in a way because if a house of lawrence
was reformed it would have to be given
more power it would have to be more of a
check on the house of commons than it
currently is and the house of commons
doesn't want that
can i just add one point i agree with
what james says but there's one point
that's very important here which is that
um the example he cites of um lawyers uh
having as it were
continuing their careers
is is is a pertinent one and also it
needs to be caveated it cannot be the
case
that the commons is filled with um
full-time mps
and um part-time mps who are also
part-time lawyers and i say that because
it cannot be the case that only
practicing lawyers continue to practice
of course in the commons
because we can't have
in my view
an ever increasing legalization of the
political class
one of the things that the commons needs
is voices for representing all sorts of
different opinions including opinions
have nothing to do with the
legality of questions but respond to the
constituents concerns about issues um
all sorts of of areas of our country
have nothing to do with law have things
to do with everyday concerns of people
so so as i say there shouldn't be a sort
of super mp who is also
a practicing lawyer but
it is it is tricky terrain um as we know
i think that there are good law um good
rules in place uh regarding uh
as james says sort of really dodgy areas
like political consultancy um but but
but this has to be said because um
oh and i added one other thing by the
way which is james is totally right
about this complete confusion among us
in the general public
on these issues of mps and mps pay we
say we don't want professional
politicians uh but we don't like people
from other professions either um
we we say that uh we want people to go
into politics with a wealth of
experience and then we expect them to
completely cut off that experience when
they get into politics this gets back to
something i think has been a problem in
our country for a while which is a sort
of
a desire effectively
with some good cause to sort of punish
the political class to catch the
politicians and the mps in particular a
kind of vice between between two things
that are screwing towards them and
keeping them locked in place i don't
think it's healthy it's not a
particularly healthy instinct for us to
have either as a public
james last word to you
so i i obviously it shouldn't just be
lawyers that you have now seconds you
should have people from from from all
walks of life but i think that lawyers
illustrate the problem with trying to
have a kind of blanket ban on all
outside interests which i think is
something that is going to gain traction
as an idea uh uh following the way that
the the government has has behaved in
recent weeks and the longer this scandal
goes on the more
uh inclination there will be for the
government to reach for some big
dramatic thing to try and move the story
on and i think that would be a mistake i
mean and so i think that is the problem
we've got to deal with i think we also
need to
work out that i think that one of the
crucial points that douglas makes is
parliament has now had powers returned
to it and i think what we've got to see
is that parliament is prepared to use
the powers that has had returned to it
and that parliament is prepared to
properly hold the executive
to account and parliament is prepared to
take more responsibility for its own
affairs
by the way i know you said the last word
to james but can we just have a moment
also to observe like a minute silence
the complete horlicks that this
government is capable of making of
absolutely everything from the smallest
uh scandal to the biggest there is
nothing that number 10 at the moment it
doesn't seem to be capable of blowing up
into a huge storm it's quite remarkable
to watch
douglas thanks for joining me and james
you're going to stay with us because
we're moving on to brexit
britain is threatening to ditch the
northern ireland protocol which governs
trade between the uk the island of
ireland and the eu in our post-brexit
era this is called triggering article
16. the agreement says that if trade is
being disrupted by the protocol the eu
and the uk have a right to suspend it by
invoking this article but the eu says
this could put the entire brexit deal in
jeopardy while the uk says that unless
the protocol is made more favorable to
britain it will be left with no other
choice
are we about to see a trade war
ivan rogers formerly the uk's permanent
representative to the eu joins us now to
discuss
now james first to you we haven't spoken
about brexit for quite a while what's
going on here
so i mean there is an expectation on the
eu side that a uk trigger of article 16
could come quite soon
maybe as soon as uh this the the cop
summit in glasgow has finished i think
what you saw when david frost went to
house of lords on wednesday there was no
time to say no no we we are not
triggering it
imminently this is not coming next week
or anything like that
and i unfortunately took i mean this is
obviously relative because david frost
is uh i think one of the most combative
diplomats that i can remember but he
took a slightly more emollient tone than
he normally does in the house of lords
uh about the eu saying that you know the
negotiations hadn't ended they were
still making some progress it just said
it wasn't anywhere near quick enough
we've also had a quite downbeat briefing
uh to eu masters in brussels from
markhasevic so the eu commission vice
president who is handling the northern
ireland question uh and so i think the
question comes you know is the uk going
to trigger article 16
if it does trigger article 16 will it
attempt to do some kind of small tweaks
using article 16 or will it attempt to
use article 16 to essentially
rewrite the protocol to
along the line set out in the uk's
command paper
and then the other question obviously
becomes how does the eu respond we know
that the french
view is that there needs to be a pretty
tough eu response and i think there is
quite a few member states you take the
view but you know you've got to show
britain that it's got to stick to
its commitments
and so i think the question is whether
you can make some progress
in uh
the coming weeks that allows the uk
ideally to not trigger article 16
ah but that is but making that progress
is going to require the uk pulling back
from some of its negotiating objectives
on things like the european court of
justice for example we'll come back to
those objectives but first ivan who's
really in the wrong here is it the eu's
fault for forcing an unworkable solution
on the uk or is it the uk's fault for
accepting it and thinking that it would
fix things later
well that probably would take longer to
try and answer properly than we've got
on this program so it's a very long
contorted history mostly unhappy i've
never been a great fan of the protocol
and obviously was deeply critical of the
way the negotiation was run
in 2017 18 19 so it doesn't surprise me
that we're here
look i think the protocol as it
currently stands
um has not been working well on the
ground and there are legitimate concerns
uh being raised by the british and
obviously by people in northern ireland
that the thing doesn't work and isn't
working as planned and there are a set i
would hope of reasonably pragmatic
things building on what the commission's
already proposed
um
on october the 13th which you could do
which would at least mitigate that and
address some of the kind of uh worst
concerns
i think as james says it goes beyond
that though if you look at the command
paper language from the uk in july and
indeed at david frost's language in
speeches subsequently and in various
other interventions and in the media
it isn't just a set of pragmatic
technical technocratic considerations
which could be smoothed away by further
negotiation technocratic level it's a an
identity and sovereignty issue
now as james says i mean i think if it
becomes genuinely an issue where the
british side says that we simply can't
accept as expansive um
a scope of
eu law operating in northern ireland and
therefore essentially the jurisdiction
of the ecj where eu law operates and
that was the basis of the protocol
solution to this
if that's the position then you're
really demanding a rather fundamental
rewrite of the protocol
and there i think we're in deep trouble
because i don't think the eu is up for a
fundamental negotiation for the protocol
i mean there are lots of pros and cons
of that as to whether they should be and
who made what areas when in 2017 to 2019
but the reality now is they think that
the british
government
under boris johnson
ultimately signed off on and ratified
and indeed proclaimed as a glorious
negotiating triumph in january 2020 this
protocol and now they want to
fundamentally reopen and rewrite it so i
think the eu side it's not incidentally
i think there are even ways in which you
could invoke article 16 which would not
be utterly inflammatory and i think
james is implying that there are ways in
which you could evoke article 16 and
that would simply create more pressure
but more space for a further negotiation
you know down in the weeds on the
technical issues but if the
fundamental issue here is the operation
the subjection of northern ireland on
trade and regulation issues to eu law
then it seems to me this is going to be
insoluble and then you're heading for a
breakdown and heading for a trade
but it crucially depends on is there a
is there a bar which frost and indeed
johnson can set which they could in
principle jump and then get enough to
declare victory on or are the concerns
so deep on the extent to which northern
ireland is subject permanently to eu law
and therefore may drift away further
from great britain
if that's the issue
then i think we're heading for the rocks
probably well james can we dig into
those objectives a bit more what are the
red lines on both sides what are the
main things they're hoping to achieve
and are you optimistic that they'll be
able to get there without something as
extreme like article 16 being triggered
occurring
so i think the eu's primary objective uh
is the protection of the integrity of
the single market uh and also the and so
to that mind uh they and they also want
to avoid a border on the island of
ireland so to that mind you basically
need to shift the border
into the irish sea which is uh what the
protocol essentially does um it creates
a trade boundary in the rsc
i mean the uk government's argument is
hang on a second this is creating too
much trade diversion which is one of the
reasons given in the protocol why it's
legitimate for article 16 to be invoked
which is one of the things about the
protocol is that because of political as
a result of a negotiation it is at some
times contradictory if you see what i
mean because uh you often hear people on
the eu side saying well supply chain
should just reorient to deal with this
yet the protocol itself says that trade
diversion would be a reason why you
could invoke article 16. um
and
uh so the the uk side is essentially
saying we are prepared to accept um
hybridity in northern ireland so eg that
you have both eu systems and uk systems
but we want those kind of running
essentially on on uk terms which is what
the argument about uh the european court
of justice is
and i mean the eu is very wary of that
because what they worry about is that
that will that will involve kind of
seepage into the single market but they
won't have proper control over their
external border and i think the question
is can you find
some way
to
um to strike a better balance than the
protocol the protocol is meant to both
protect the integrity of a single market
and respect the good friday agreement
i i think you can argue that at the
moment it is overly weighted in favor of
protecting the integrity of a single
market rather than a good friday
agreement which obviously talks about
east-west as well as north-south and i
think you could also argue that although
this is a word that creates a neuralgic
reaction among
lots of people in brussels but there is
a case for more pragmatism for accepting
that for example you know going slightly
further than the sasquatch proposals and
saying look whatever the uk does on food
regulations you know we are going to
allow sausages to cross from great
britain into northern ireland as long as
they are they are going to kind of
trusted traders and they are clearly
marked but they are not to be sold on um
into the into the into the republic and
the and therefore the eu single market i
mean i personally think that that if you
did allow that you would not suddenly
see you know british sausages um
taking over the black market sausage
factory so you know i i think that is an
unlikely concern so i mean the question
is can you strike that but i think the
issue is the the uk by putting the ecj
issue on the table have basically forced
everyone to focus on the fundamentals
and sometimes for forcing everyone to
focus on the fundamentals of negotiation
isn't actually conducive to getting to a
negotiated outcome
ivan if things were to go badly wrong in
this negotiation to what extent do you
think the entire trade agreement between
the uk and the eu is at stake
oh i think it is i'm afraid at that
point now um
i agree with what james said and there
is a differentiation here as i said
between the kind of the pragmatic needs
of the greater freer circulation of
goods and and much closer to uh the
status quo anti-brexit and whether that
is deliverable building on what
commission so far proposed which the
british side is saying doesn't go far
enough i would be amazed at the
pragmatic level if the commission didn't
have some more room for maneuver in
their back pocket but it crucially
depends on whether that's the basis of
the negotiation and therefore you can
scrabble around in sanitary and photo
sanitary and customs issues
and find a compromise or whether it's
really about governance ecj and the role
of eu law and the risk from the british
perspective that this thing
drags northern ireland progressively
into a different economic zone in
perpetuity
an even more serious conflict though
could soon erupt in asia i'm joined now
by elbridge colby who worked at the
pentagon under donald trump and was the
architect of the administration's
defense strategy in this week's magazine
he says the united states needs to be
ready to go to war over taiwan
he's the author of strategy of denial
american defense in an age of great
power conflict and he joins me now
bridge thanks for joining spectator tv
china has built models of u.s warships
in the desert for target practice and is
tested using passenger ferries to
transport troops and vehicles for an
invasion of taiwan joe biden meanwhile
says the u.s will defend taiwan if china
invades
how likely is war over taiwan
well i think it's definitely possible if
not increasingly probable i mean there's
i think three three things going on one
is the chinese clearly have the will to
do something about it i mean they wanted
to bring taiwan into the communist fold
since this end of the civil war
uh and it's also uh important for their
regional and global ambitions because
it's connected to the united states and
uh that's sort of the big the big
problem for china is to kind of break
this uh coalition that's forming to
blunt those ambitions secondly they've
now got much more of a way to do
something about as you mentioned kate
they're doing mock-ups and and target
practice on american aircraft carriers
which tells you how serious they are and
they of course wanted that to be noticed
that's not the kind of thing you do if
you want to remain hidden the third
thing that's
going on is they
uh they may see a window of opportunity
uh the u.s is finally if too slowly and
fitfully turning to focus on asia and
some are our military investments will
start to pay off but only later in the
decade or into the next decade and so
china may see a window and the other
thing to remember kate is
that you know china has tried to bring
taiwan to the fold through peaceful
means coercion gray zone tactics for
many many years in fact decades and
failed and they know that they know that
and so if they really want to do it
they're likely to look at the military
instruments so at some point
if the military balance doesn't go back
in our favor i think the question will
be why won't they not not why will they
in your book you say that taiwan matters
to china because it wants regional
hegemony over asia meaning that it wants
to be the undisputed dominant power
can you explain why taiwan is a key part
of that
sure well and the primary reason is that
you know
for china to get to this regionally
hegemonic
position it doesn't want to start a huge
war hitler-like with everybody uh all at
the same time which is it's likely to
lose and would be extremely costly in
any case the key for china rather is to
kind of break apart this aborting
anti-hegemonic coalition i call it this
you know quad august all these different
things that are happening in the u.s
india
japan etc etc all right so how does
china do that if it doesn't want to
start world war you know
a total war
well it goes after those parts of the
coalition that uh in a way that would
diminish or undermine confidence in that
coalition that people will basically not
be defended
and to do that it needs to go after the
countries actually paradoxically that
are connected to the united states so
think the best thing that ever happened
in nato after the cold war was russia
going into ukraine because it indicated
that russia was afraid of nato right
that ukraine wasn't in nato so that
actually drove people towards nato in
the united states so if china wants to
actually you know put a a knife into the
heart of that anti-hegemonic coalition
it's gotta undermine people's confidence
in america's willingness to effectively
defend them and taiwan is connected to
the united states i think as you pointed
out the president and others have
indicated that we have a rock-solid
commitment to taiwan it's based on
decades of behavior and so forth and so
actually china does have an interest in
in
seizing taiwan for a variety of reasons
and then presenting the united states
with just a really difficult problem to
reverse and then people will say can we
really trust the americans that will
that could cause a run on the bank and
and if they don't do it with taiwan they
might not have to do it that many more
times before people really lose
confidence
and as you say on the flip side it's
america's goal to stop china from
achieving the such money over asia in
the current balance who's winning well i
mean
the question of a balance is is is much
more
sort of focused and localized than
people often appreciate you know because
china's best strategy is to go after
taiwan and then kind of reset the board
we're losing in that particular context
um
you know basically senior military
officials are saying that when they do
war games we we don't do well in fact we
lose we kind of know what to do about it
but we're not doing anything about it so
the fact that the united states still
has a larger you know economy and market
exchange terms is not really the most
important issue because the contest is
going to be settled in asia um and you
know
pay tribute to winston churchill here um
uh you know the key logic here is if we
get things right in the decisive theater
we can put everything right afterwards
uh you know again but the reverse
doesn't hold true and the thing is that
the military balance and the power
balance is not going in the right
direction in asia and that's something
that we really need to focus on
rectifying immediately and urgently
and you write in this week's magazine
that the us needs to build a coalition
in the region that's stronger than china
who would be part of that coalition
sure well the cornerstones of japan and
india are the the kind of the major
powers that are sort of a second tier
that are immediately threatened by china
obviously countries that that you know
for various reasons are opposed to china
basically they want to maintain their
independence and autonomy australia
taiwan possibly south korea possibly uh
vietnam uh it's going to be kind of a
patchwork of countries that the primary
uh cohesive aspect is going to be their
shared opposition to being dominated by
china not
you know what their political form
government is not what their religion is
not what language they speak um so
that's going to be the main the main the
main draw the key thing is that again
it's going to be about that regional
balance it's primarily going to be asian
countries that are going to matter
because they have the skin in the game
and they have the military and economic
power in the region where where things
are going to be decided
and to what extent does this coalition
need to grow or strengthen because some
of the countries you just listed there i
mean most of them these are strong
allies of the united states already so
how does it further cement its
relationship uh to build up that that
stance against china
sure well the paradoxes we we got to
avoid two two polar risks one is under
committing having too few countries as
you suggest the other is over committing
we don't want to get into a repeat of
the vietnam war where we go too far and
we end up in wars we probably don't
really need to fight so the thing is yes
i think you're right that we need to
build a coalition that's expansive we
want the countries that are involved
certainly ones that we the americans are
specifically connected to to be
defensible and that basically means
islands i mean it's simple but you know
the united states great britain
traditionally better at naval uh
aerospace high technology warfare that's
where we don't want to get drawn on the
asian mainland if we can if we can
possibly avoid it to countries that
can't defend themselves like india so i
think that's what we're going to need to
look at the something that's often
unappreciated in taiwan context is if we
lose taiwan we will have to dramatically
compensate both in pure power terms
taiwan is a large economy it's got a
significant you know power position but
it's also people are really going to
question our credibility so we're going
to have to add a lot more countries to
our effort and that's going to create
new vulnerabilities that people don't
adequately appreciate if the united
states and its allies were to win a
conflict in taiwan you write about
increasing the burden of escalation
that is persuading china that a small
conflict over taiwan shouldn't become a
large-scale war
how do you persuade beijing fearing a
wider decline not to lash out
well i don't want to minimize what the
war over taiwan would be it would be a
large-scale war but i think it would not
necessarily become a total war which is
a possibility uh we can't be sure what
would happen uh but we'd have to be
prepared for a limited war because if
china's prepared for a limited war and
we're not we will always be checkmated
because they'll be willing to uh risk
take risks that we won't also be willing
to do uh the key there is not only to
the the burden of escalation is not only
about the costs that we can impose you
know so the fact that china will uh
induce uh the united states and others
to impose more costs on them it's also
about the china having uh sort of a
graceful exit a reason to acknowledge
if not defeat frustration i mean i think
the example i make and it's not a great
one but it's satisfactory is the
situation on the korean peninsula since
1953 there's no peace agreement it's
still an armistice but that's been
satisfactory for us and south korea uh
which is obviously a marvel of
development and so forth so i think what
we will need to think about in this
context actually is not only what are
the costs and penalties we can impose on
china but what are the reasons china
will have
to
you know uh sort of point to as
positives in in terminating a war even
if implicitly rather than explicitly
uh last question to you bridge how does
this potential conflict with china in
the coming months and years measure up
against other things like russian
aggression or iran's nuclear ambitions
other problems that the west faces
sure
well i think it's important to be very
clear and i one of the problems i have
with the current administration is i
don't think they're being clear with our
european and middle eastern partners i
mean look the fundamental reality from
an american point of view i think
objectively is asia is by far the most
important theater of the world it's
going to be about 50 of global gdp and
that fraction is growing and by far the
most significant other power in the
international system is china it's far
far more consequential
than russia russia is a threat to nato
and nato is an important interest but it
pales in significance to
uh to asia which is you know roughly
double of europe's share of gdp and
actually relatively increasing so if if
the united states is pressed into making
a decision which current european
behavior not that of the united kingdom
but of others like germany is
essentially going to force the united
states to make a choice because the
reality is that we don't we have from a
number of years we have not had a
military that is sufficiently large to
fight two major power wars with china
and russia so if we think about that as
a practical consequence not only do we
if china goes first well we have to
focus focus on asia but in my view even
if russia goes first in europe we should
withhold military capacity to deter a
chinese attack on taiwan or another ally
in the western pacific so this is going
to leave a major vacuum
in europe i mean that's that's the basic
that's the fundamental reality uh which
i would rather that this not be the case
um but you know there's also a very
natural way to plug this gap which is
that the members of european nato and
close to it like the finns and the
swedes uh far outweigh russia in gdp
terms and latent military power as well
so they can plug the gap and many of
them are the united kingdom deserves
enormous credit for raising its defense
spending during the pandemic the polls
are spending a lot on defense and highly
capable defensive forces the big problem
is basically germany and i think all
european and and north american states
need to bring intense and searching
pressure on the federal republic to do
its part i mean nobody benefited more
from collective defense than west
germany and indeed a unified germany and
now they are fundamentally shirking
their responsibilities in a way that i
think is unconscionable but forget about
unconscionable i don't think it's in
their interests over time because if
they do if they do allow this vacuum and
the russians see an opportunity
they might act and in that context i
don't think the united states will be
there to save their bacon and uh so i
hope the europeans will step up
but not everybody agrees taiwan is
strategically important i'm joined now
by emma ashford a senior fellow at the
atlantic council and a columnist for
foreign policy
emma we've heard from elbridge colby
there who thinks the u.s needs to get
serious about preparing for a war with
taiwan do you agree
i think that um
elbridge colby has some some great ideas
i think he really understands security
dynamics in asia but i do think that
there are some serious flaws in his
arguments and i think he overlooks some
of the serious risks to us security and
prosperity that could come about if we
actually followed his advice
up until now u.s policy towards taiwan
has been strategically ambiguous but joe
biden is being increasingly clear that
the u.s will defend taiwan in the event
of an invasion
what do you make of this strategy do you
think that's actually ramping things up
or do you think that's making very clear
to china which may be a country not
actually prepared to go to war that it
needs to back down on the aggressive
moves that it's been making certainly in
terms of showing off its military might
so there's some some ambiguity in the
administration's position too um you
know joe biden has as you say made a
couple of comments oh we're obligated to
defend taiwan um and then the
administration has walked those back
pretty quickly through the pentagon
spokesperson and other officials um and
so the official u.s policy is still
ambiguity and i think it's important to
remember um you know that ambiguity has
some benefits for the us in particular
one i'd highlight is that it also allows
us to keep a handle on taiwanese
nationalism so one of the reasons why
taiwan has never actually declared
itself a country is because of the
ambiguity of that u.s commitment
so in keeping our stance ambiguous as we
have done since the 70s we keep both
sides um the chinese from from
escalating and the taiwanese from
escalating that conflict in a way that
we don't want and so i worry that a more
concrete commitment
would just sort of give taiwan a reason
to escalate this as well and then we
would have escalation on both sides
i suppose the argument goes that you
can't stay in a limbo forever and the
covet crisis exasperated that especially
when taiwan was being kept out of key
decisions and and key meetings being
held by the who for example uh around
the spread of the pandemic i'm not sure
why we couldn't keep that status quo
going it has as i say served as well for
almost five decades um
and i think you know we we the argument
that we're having about whether to offer
a more concrete commitment to taiwan um
you know it sounds great in theory right
it's rhetorically you know we're going
we're going to defend a democracy we're
going to defend them against chinese
aggression um we're offering them a
commitment that would be comparable to
the one we offer to our nato allies um
but again that downplays the associated
costs right it obligates us to go to war
if the chinese were to try something
against taiwan and you know it doesn't
even have to be sort of a full frontal
military assault right there are lots of
um you know what we used to call salami
slicing during the cold war there's lots
of things that china could do um to call
that commitment into question and if we
have made a concrete commitment um then
u.s policy makers find our options are a
lot more limited than they would be
otherwise
it does seem however with the creation
of also this coalition between australia
the uk and the u.s that there is more
appetite now uh certainly here in the uk
but but also in washington dc to be much
more upfront about the pushback that
china should expect to receive if it
were to step over certain red lines i
think that's true and to be clear just
because i'm arguing that we shouldn't
give a concrete security commitment to
taiwan doesn't mean that i don't think
that a rising china is somewhat of a
threat to the us
it doesn't mean that i'm not worried
about chinese advances in asia
but taiwan is a very small piece of that
overall puzzle there are major countries
in the region that the us has already
aligned with japan and south korea that
we're allied with
there are a variety of small diverse
countries in southeast asia you know
there's the whole indian subcontinent
that we can work with as you say the
indians the australians there's there
are lots of countries that the u.s can
work with that are more important than
taiwan um and so i'm not arguing that we
shouldn't be pushing back against china
i'm not arguing we should be concerned
about china i'm just saying i don't
think that taiwan
is the place that the us should be
making that as you say red line
emma lastly where do you think that this
power rivalry is headed with china
towards conflict or do you think there's
a possibility we're actually moving
towards more competition
well i mean i don't know um and i think
anyone that tells you otherwise is lying
um but but you know i'll tell you sort
of the both answers um so one is that
you know we live in a fundamentally
different era than the era prior to
world war ii and that is because of
nuclear weapons right
and that may make um conflict between
the great powers less likely um but no
one's very sure of that right we don't
have a lot of historical evidence we
don't have cases to draw from so that is
basically a wager that we might not
expect conflict um and sort of the other
option is that conflict is very possible
um and if you read um phoebe albridge
colby's book he argues that you know
because china is rising is going to want
asian hegemony it's going to try and
push the us out of the region
and you know war in that situation i
think is likely um
even if you don't agree with him that
china is this you know assertive
aggressive revisionist power um we know
from history that there's always the
risk of miscalculation misperception
security spirals that accidentally turn
into a conflict you know everything from
you know world war one to much smaller
conflicts have been caused by these
factors and so i think you know we
should be aware that war is a
possibility um but the answer probably
isn't to just start building up our
military and expecting a war because
that could become a self-fulfilling
prophecy
finally the israeli ambassador to the uk
sippy hataveli was hounded by protesters
after she attended a debate at the
london school of economics take a look
[Applause]
[Music]
why did they want the ambassador
silenced she joins me now to discuss
ambassador thanks so much for joining
spectator tv
first can you give us your account of
what happened to lse
sure um students in lse invited me to
give a lecture about israel and i gave a
lecture in lse which was excellent and
what was excellent basically was the
dialogue the opportunity for the
students to ask me questions some of
them were challenging and to have open
dialogue with the young generation here
in on campus is one of my main goals
and i want to say that from my opinion
um the the fact that there were
protesters outside that were trying to
prevent
the legitimate right of every person
definitely ambassador of a friendly
country and a democratic country like
israel to
to just you know change views in campus
is something that is outrageous and it
shouldn't have happened and of course
everyone can criticize or protest but
not in a violent way not by saying
horrible things about
hurting me and my car like some people
uh published on social media and i'm
very proud of the fact that the british
government was so clear with with um you
know condemning uh the people there
using violence in order to intimidate
representatives of a democratic country
and i think it's very clear that we're
not intimidated and we are going to go
everywhere and israel is going to be um
making uh the message and the voice of
the israeli people because this is my
job as ambassador
ambassador attempts to intimidate you
threats of violence do you get this a
lot
during the military operation in gaza
unfortunately there were many many
violent act actions
and there are the same people the same
people that were burning israeli flags
in front of the embassy the people that
were
coming with convoys in my neighborhood
calling anti-semite statements in in the
streets they're basically coming from
the same mindset and i'm saying again
the british government made it clear i
mean i got a phone call from home
secretary yesterday she said that this
is unacceptable
the fact that they were trying to
cancel my lecture or they were trying to
make the university doesn't feel
comfortable with the fact that
ambassador is coming look this is
something that no other ambassador
experienced in the u in the uk think
about it there's so many ambassadors
here many countries that uh the uk can
speak about uh you know different
different mindset of uh ideologies uh
countries like china countries like iran
but you will never see the same
aggression again against those
ambassadors and of course i'm against
any kind of violence i'm here for a
dialogue but think about it why should a
democratic country the only democratic
country in the middle east will have
this kind of um
i would say a violent aggressive uh
outreach from from students when when
all i want to do is to speak and to have
a dialogue with the students this is
unacceptable what did you make of the
fact that this incident in lse took
place on the 83rd anniversary of the
crystal knocked where more than 90 g's
were killed in nazi germany
i think there is no connection between
the the horrible history of germany and
what is happening in this country
because in this country the government
is is so strict about fighting
anti-semitism and and definitely
gives all the protection that i need i'm
surrounded by british protection
wonderful people my protection team is
doing everything in order to make sure
that i will do my work everywhere and um
they never prevent
anything that is about a public stage to
happen so i'm definitely thankful and
grateful for the fact that this country
understands where the
the red line crosses and what is
legitimate and and something that is
unlegitimate like preventing or
silencing ambassadors
you say that you're very grateful to the
uk government for the way that they've
supported you that broadly speaking it
was a very good debate where there was
probably sure very fierce debate and
rigorous analysis of your comments but
then on the other side you say that you
often feel singled out as far as
ambassadors go because you are
representing the state of israel how do
you weigh this up in the way that you
interpret the uk do you consider this to
be an open and tolerant country
absolutely i think that those radicals
are minority their vocal minority they
definitely don't represent the majority
not of the students definitely not the
people of this country and i think this
is how we need to to take care of it as
a minority and and this is something
that uh
it's very clear for me since i arrived
that the uk
is very happy to do bilateral
cooperations with israel i can see that
with
the meeting that we hold just last week
in cop 26 between our prime ministers
prime minister bennett went to cop and
um we had the second large delegation
here and prime minister johnson prime
minister bennett had excellent meeting
so you can see the bilateral um
cooperation is just growing and and the
relationship is great so we shouldn't
let those voices of radicals to
interrupt the legitimate dialogue that
every ambassador should hold with all
parts of british society
are you going to change the way that you
attend or speak at universities in the
future based on what happened to lse
this week
absolutely not i'm going to attend to
every single lecture
of important campus in this country and
this country has many many important
academic institutions
that you should be very proud of but you
should also
make sure that freedom of you know the
whole concept of universities is
exchanging views and the ability to to
have
free speech everywhere and i think that
the government
is is definitely doing its best to to
make the atmosphere the right atmosphere
on campus but the radicals shouldn't
shape the discourse it's actually the
people that care about the future of
this country should make sure that every
student should feel free
to uh you know to feel comfortable on
campus some some students said they were
really intimidated from
um the sounds they heard from the
protesters and they were shouting and
screaming and trying to intimidate the
students so i think this kind of
atmosphere is not a good thing in campus
campus should be free and campus should
be open-minded to to a dialogue
last question ambassador from your
perspective what was the divide amongst
the protesters because of course the
right to protest is a crucial part of
the right to free speech but what seemed
to happen earlier this week was that
that delicate balance flipped from
protesting to some real aggression that
you experienced was the whole crowd like
that or were these again individuals
amongst those who were politely or at
least calmly protesting
well it's the police job to make the
decision who was crossing lines and who
was uh you know doing things against the
law but
from my perspective i can only tell you
my experience as an ambassador that we
heard about a big pressure to cancel the
lecture
and those people again some of them are
part of
you know the palestinian groups in on
campus
they don't want the voice of israel to
be heard i i never as an ambassador said
don't listen to someone i think every
sound definitely
of you know people that are being
invited by the students should be sound
on campus and i think the fact they're
trying to create the legitimation of a
democratic country that is a strong ally
of the uk
this is the problem and and again they
were trying to delegitimize the lecture
delegitimize the voice of israel on
campus and i'm very glad that the
message of the university of lsc was we
will never accept silenting a legitimate
voice and i was giving the lecture it
was an hour and a half of a very nice
and very interesting dialogue
ambassador thanks for joining me
that's it for this week if you enjoyed
this episode don't forget to subscribe
to the spectator's youtube channel just
click the button at the bottom of this
video and tap the bell icon to make sure
you never miss an episode
thanks for watching and do join us again
next week
[Music]
you